ahora que tenemos más familiaridad con
las transformaciones lineales lo que
quiero hacer es tratar de construir más
cosas a partir de ellas entonces vamos a
suponer que empieza con una
transformación lineal s que va de un
conjunto x en un conjunto y vamos a
suponer que x es un subconjunto de r n
entonces x está contenido en rn podría
ser todo rn pero no necesariamente y
vamos a suponer que ya está contenido en
r m así que tengo una transformación que
va de un subconjunto de rn a un
subconjunto de rm y como ese es lineal
yo sé que eso se puede representar
mediante una matriz entonces s de un
vector x un vector x que esté en el
subconjunto x es decir x pertenece a x
pero x está contenido en de rn así que x
pertenece a r
y bueno sbx es lo mismo que una matriz a
por el vector x ahora bien
qué dimensiones tiene la matriz pues el
vector x pertenece a rn así que es una
matriz de n columnas y el vector sf x
está en ya que está contenido en r m así
que tiene que ser una matriz de gm x
muy bien entonces vamos a hacer algunos
dibujos tengo
tengo mi conjunto x
el conjunto x que está contenido en r m
y tengo
y tengo mi conjunto de dominio que está
contenido en r m y entonces si yo tengo
algún vector en él en su conjunto x lo
puedo enviar lo puedo asociar mediante
la transformación con algún vector en g
esto sería mediante este muy bien ahora
supongamos ahora supongamos que tengo
otra transformación lineal t
que ahora va del subconjunto de rm
un subconjunto z donde z
z está contenido en r le vamos a decir
recuerden que en m y l pueden tomar
cualquier valor que yo quiera bien
entonces este también es una
transformación lineal
y entonces lo que tengo es un
subconjunto z por acá
acá tengo a z que está contenido en r él
y entonces puedo
puedo transformar elementos de g
los puedo asociar o los puedo enviar a
elementos de z mediante la
transformación de
noten que como t es una transformación
lineal que se puede representar mediante
una matriz así que si tengo de x para
alguna x en el conjunto y no se vayan a
confundir con esta x esta x está en el
conjunto que es un subconjunto de rm así
que x pertenece a rm
entonces tv x es igual al producto de
una matriz b por el vector x así que
esta matriz b tiene que tener m columnas
porque va de rm y llega a rl así que
tiene que tener el renglones así que es
una matriz de l por m muy bien ahora una
pregunta natural que quizás les ha
surgido es habrá algún modo de definir
una transformación que vaya desde x
hasta zeta de algún modo natural que
involucre a las transformaciones s&p y
pues vamos a ver que si lo hay vamos a
definir
vamos a definir lo que es la composición
vamos a definir una nueva transformación
que va a ser
de compuesta con s s circulito de y se
le compuesta con que va a ser una
transformación que va desde x hasta zeta
desde x hasta zeta todo el camino y se
va a llamar
te compuesta con ese se llama
se llama la composición
la composición
d
la composición de té con
efe bien y cómo funciona esta
composición o cómo actúa esta
transformación pues lo natural lo
natural sería si comienza con un vector
x en mi subconjunto x de rn entonces
aplicarle la transformación lineal s
para obtener un vector en el subconjunto
y que sería ese de x ahora esto este
valor es un es un elemento del
subconjunto de rm así que es un vector
en rm por lo tanto yo también puedo
aplicarle la transformación de a ese
vector así que ahora aplico t
y llegaría a este vector de aquí que
sería p de quien te dé s de x igual y
esto se ve un poco rimbombante pero en
realidad ese de x es sencillamente un
miembro del conjunto y es un vector en
el subconjunto de rm así que voy a hacer
la siguiente definición voy a definir
entonces una definición a la
transformación t compuesta con s
aplicada a un vector x
como pues que fue lo que hice primero
tomé s x s de x primero aplique s para
obtener el vector sf x y después y
después aplique la transformación t así
que
te compuesta con ese aplicado un vector
x simplemente significa apliquen primero
es el vector x y al resultado apliquen
lete entonces la pregunta natural que no
surge o que nos debería surgir al menos
es t y s t y s eran transformaciones
lineales así que esta cosa esté
compuesta con s es una
transformación lineal transformación
tener información
bien para checar que algo sea lineal
tengo que checar dos cosas distintas
primero que nada tengo que checar que la
transformación aplicada a una suma de
dos vectores sea igual a la suma de la
transformación aplicada a cada vector
individualmente esos son un poco enredos
o así que mejor vamos a escribirlo lo
que tengo que ver es que te compuesta
con ese aplicado a una suma de vectores
vamos a decir
vamos a tomarnos a dos vectores en el
subconjunto x de rn vamos a decir x
y entonces esté compuesta con x aplicado
a x + d
es igual a que pues esto es por
definición de d s d
x más y ahora bien yo sé que ese es una
transformación lineal ese es una
transformación lineal así que esto esté
de
s de x
más ese de que esta es una de las
propiedades que tienen las
transformaciones lineales ya la hemos
discutido en muchas ocasiones en el
pasado lo que puedo hacer es sustituir
esto de aquí por esto de acá pues ese es
una transformación lineal entonces esas
dos cosas son iguales y bien esto ahora
uso que t es una transformación lineal
estos dos son vectores en r m son
miembros de iu así que eso me dice que
esto es
d
s de x
más
d
ese de
pero ahora quién es esto pues esto
simplemente es de compuesto con ese por
definición aplicado al vector x
más de compuesta con s aplicada al
vector
así que se cumple que la transformación
aplicada a la suma de dos vectores es la
suma de la transformación aplicada a
cada vector individualmente ahora ahora
tengo que checar que la transformación
aplicada a un múltiplo escalar de un
vector sea el mismo múltiple escalar de
la transformación aplicada directamente
al vector es decir es decir si tengo t
compuesta con ese y se lo aplicó a un
múltiplo de un vector x que pertenece a
nuestro dominio y de hecho aquí tenemos
que tener cuidado porque el vector c por
equis también tiene que estar en el
conjunto x pero bueno no nos preocupemos
por eso por ahora esto quién es pues
esto por definición de nuevo este de s
de c por el vector x recuerden que ese
es un escalar y eso quién es pues eso es
lo mismo que t
d
recuerden que ese es una transformación
lineal así que estoy aquí es lo mismo
que se el escalarse por s de x eso se
sigue de que s es una transformación
lineal así que s de un múltiple escalar
de un vector es el múltiple escalar de
ese del vector
me pongo este paréntesis del color que
debería ser
y ahora bien de nuevo te es una
transformación lineal así que esto es lo
mismo que se por
de quién pues de ese de equis
pero esta hora quién es simplemente es c
x
te compuesta con s d el vector x así que
este requerimiento también se cumple de
modo que si es una transformación lineal
si se trata de una transformación lineal
pues cumple con los dos requisitos que
se necesitan para hacer una
transformación lineal ahora surge una
pregunta interesante pues yo sé que si
esta transformación te compuesta con ese
es una transformación lineal entonces te
compuesta con dice se puede representar
me sientan mediante una matriz es decir
te compuesta con ese aplicada a un
vector x debe ser lo mismo que alguna
matriz de ave
vamos a usar de alguna matriz de
multiplicada por el vector x y ahora
bien como t compuesta con s t compuesta
con s va de x en zeta y x es un
subconjunto de r n
iceta es un subconjunto de rl entonces
esta matriz de debe ser de l renglones
n columnas es una matriz de l por n y en
el próximo vídeo
vamos a averiguar quién es
explícitamente esta matriz de en
relación a las matrices a ive que
representan a ese yate respectivamente
así que bueno nos vemos en el próximo